how do you feel about YouTube content
and the longer one the way I think about
word form in long form is the way I
think about a basketball how much money
have you made because the invention of
the basketball me I'm negative because
I've had two knee surgeries already but
LeBron is going to make billions because
of it the piano zero for me quite a bit
for Billy Joel and Elton John that's how
this all is when people are like social
doesn't work for our industry or for me
yes it does it doesn't work for you you
suck at it so long form short form they
both work some people are really good at
like one-liners and they're comedy
writers and they've got improv DNA and
they Crush in short other people are
just like you know they got real
substance